d'habitude c'est un jour de fête
d'habitude on récolte 50 hectolitres de
plus à l'hectare en détruisant le raisin
le gel a donné aux vendanges un goût de
nostalgie l'habitude de s'arrêter à
paris ce qui l'est c'est que tu as sauf
que je chauffe night lights faut marcher
au marché pour trouver une moindre grave
qu'on peut trouver l'amitié nous sommes
assez combien les poubelles de raisin là
dans la dans une imprimerie
c'est dix fois plus qu'aujourd'hui
d'habitude il ya foule dans les rangs
cette année ils ne sont que 4 et ça
suffit bien 80 % de la récolte est
perdue
c'est une année c'est une année blanche
comme on dit ce n'est pour rien et on va
essayer ben on va essayer de tenir comme
ça et on va venir avec le stock en fait
on va vivre et qu'avec les réserves
qu'on a on avait fait des années qu'ils
ont la grâce au stock on va pouvoir
faire face à toutes les dépenses et des
charges de l'entreprise
et puis espérons que ça va pas se
reproduire l'année suivante de manière à
reconstituer un stock pour les deux
étant le stockage est une assurance mais
tout le monde n'a pas les moyens de se
l'offrir des frais d'entretien élevés et
une imposition sur chaque bouteille non
vendus
les jeunes exploitation ne peuvent pas
se le permettre pour elle le déficit
sera cruel d'autant que le gel aura des
conséquences à long terme car les cèpes
eux-mêmes ont souffert et un piége les
repousse mal nécessite plus de travail
résultat les coûts de production vont
grimper dans les années à venir on va
passer plus de temps à former de note
seb du fait que le tailleur va réfléchir
sur la meilleure solution possible pour
remettre le cep en état et on passera
peut-être que 30 à 40% de plus de temps
à l'hectare et la masse salariale va
doubler bref en une année de gel
on récolte des ennuis pour cinq ans cela
pourrait être le dernier dicton à la
mode chez les viticulteurs